[Music]  should I do  what send an emoji okay you cool  welcome to the secret world inside your  phone  we're emojis like me work and live here  each of us does one thing and we have to  nail it every time we are go for men huh  what the heck  my friend Jean here has a little problem  oh how are you doing that it's just  something I can do can you help us  follow me we need to get off the phone  and find the source code that's bro my  Felicia you need to get the master  password  it was Tina  Karen Sara I want to say Lupita  but that doesn't feel right now I'm  saying out loud I think you're pretty  cool just the way you are  [Music]  my feelings are huge maybe I'm meant to  have more than just one emotion  candy crush goodbye sweet never eaten  another piece of candy ever again  high five don't do it don't you do it  it's already been in there once okay son  what do we do after we go potty should  we wash our hands  [Music]